Olá esse é o vídeo mais importante que
você vai assistir sobre essa vitamina
tão essencial que é a B9 o ácido fólico
ou mesmo folato muita gente toma
suplementos de B9 mas talvez não faça
ideia do que que eu vou explicar aqui
então você pode estar comprando
suplementos de folato e jogando dinheiro
fora E para piorar você pode continuar
com a falta dessa vitamina no corpo
mesmo tomando suplemento Além disso você
pode também está com excesso de B9 O que
pode causar diversos sintomas e
problemas você deve estar confuso não é
como pode estar tomando suplemento de B9
ainda ter deficiência então Preste
atenção no que eu vou explicar pois
suplementar a vitamina B9 não é tão
simples como parece Primeiro vamos
entender os termos folato é a vitamina
B9 na sua forma natural que é encontrada
nos alimentos metilfolato um tempo que
você já certamente deve ter ouvido falar
é a forma ativa da vitamina B9 nos
suplementos é a forma que o corpo
utiliza diretamente sem necessidade de
conversão já o ácido fólico é a forma
sintética da vitamina B9 em que o corpo
Precisa converter o ácido fólico em
folato ativo para utilizar então quando
comemos alimentos extraímos o folato a
vitamina B9 desses alimentos quando
tomamos suplementos de B9 geralmente
tomamos ácido fólico a forma sintética
ou metilfolato a forma metilada se você
está tomando suplementos de ácido fólico
todos os dias como se fosse balinha
precisa entender uma coisa esse
suplemento que é a forma sintética
também está presente em vários alimentos
fortificados principalmente
industrializados farinhas brancas trigo
e milho você deve estar se perguntando
por que que eu estou falando disso já
que sabemos que a maioria das mulheres
grávidas receb prescrição de ácido
fólico que é fundamental pra saúde na
gravidez e do bebê O problema é que
muitas pessoas acham que por ser uma
vitamina bastante prescrita não há
problemas em consumir livremente ou em
excesso mas o excesso de ácido fólico
sintético pode ser prejudicial
principalmente porque o corpo Precisa
converter o ácido fólico na forma ativa
o folato e essa conversão Nem sempre é
eficiente para vocês terem uma ideia
mais de 30% das pessoas não conseguem
converter o ácido fólico na forma ativa
ou não consegu de maneira eficiente pelo
menos ou seja 30% das pessoas estão
usando ácido fólico sem obter os
melhores benefícios portanto é muito
importante saber que é melhor e mais
seguro usar a forma metilada da vitamina
B9 que é o metilfolato inclusive na
gravidez para entender melhor Imagine
que o ácido fólico sintético é como o
petróleo bruto assim como não podemos
colocar o petróleo bruto diretamente no
tanque de um carro porque ele precisa
ser refinado para se tornar um
combustível
utilizável o ácido fólico também precisa
ser convertido em folato pelo corpo para
poder ser utilizado Então esse processo
de conversão no corpo é chamado de
metilação se a metilação não funcionar
bem devido a problemas genéticos ou
outros problemas o corpo vai acumular
esse ácido fólico não convertido O que
pode causar sintomas então se você
estiver tomando o ácido fólico sintético
e o seu corpo não estiver convertendo de
forma adequada estará acumulando esse
excesso e o que que pode acontecer a
partir disso você pode ter ansiedade
piora da depressão TDAH que é o
transtorno de Déficit de Atenção mais
comum nas crianças ou
hiperatividade pode haver piora dos
sintomas de toque que eu transtorno
obsessivo
compulsivo Você pode ter dificuldade
concentração e dificuldade para dormir
já que a mente fica muito agitada pelo
excesso não convertido circulando então
níveis elevados de ácido fólico não
metabolizado no corpo podem também
causar alterações dos hormônios sexuais
impactar em deficiência de certos
nutrientes e até camuflar uma
deficiência de B12 então altos níveis de
ácido fólico persistente no sangue estão
até mesmo ligados ao desenvolvimento de
câncer de acordo com algumas pesquisas
existem vários estudos que mostram uma
ligação entre suplementação excessiva de
ácido fólico ou a su obtenção de
alimentos fortificados como grãos de
cereais e pães com o crescimento de
células
pré-cancerosas as Farinhas de trigo e de
milho são obrigados a serem fortificados
com ferro e ácido fólico infelizmente
isso é lamentável pessoal eles utilizam
isso porque ácido fólico é uma forma
mais estável que não se degrada
facilmente e permanece no alimento mas
ainda assim é uma forma sintética não
natural para nosso corpo que terá
dificuldade de processar em pelo menos
30% das pessoas então se você consome
muitos desses alimentos fortificados
ainda suplementa com ácido fólico Você
pode ter problemas porque pode se
acumular no seu corpo claro que isso vai
causar problemas quando em grandes
quantidades Mas se você tiver uma
mutação que dificulta essa conversão do
ácido fólico você estará suplementando
mas Continuará deficiente vitamina B9 e
ao mesmo tempo estará com excesso de
ácido fólico sintético circulante deixe
suas dúvidas nos comentários que eu vou
fazer o máo para respondê-las Ok bom
então estamos falando que mais de 30%
das pessoas não consegu converter o ócio
fólico na sua forma utilizável de
maneira eficiente devido a mutações
genéticas o que vai levar uma
deficiência funcional de folato mesmo
com uma ingestão dietética adequada e
isso pode resultar em níveis elevados de
homocisteína no sangue que é aminoácido
que em altas concentrações pode estar
associado ao maior risco de doenças
cardiovasculares aumento do risco de
ataque cardíaco de infarto de derrame
até câncer
Além disso complicações na gravidez
demência depressão e outros problemas de
saúde você pode estar se perguntando
como saber se você faz parte desse grupo
com mutações genéticas é um grupo bem
grande de pessoas que tem esse problema
então essas mutações
genéticas estão relacionadas ao folato e
dificultam ainda mais obter a quantidade
suficiente de vitamina B9 então muitas
vezes asas pessoas precisam Arão tomar a
B9 na formativa metilfolato pelo resto
da vida mas para saber se você tem essas
mutações é importante é necessário fazer
exame genético o exame da Mutação do
mthfr e os mais comuns são as variantes
c677t e a
298c então esses exames são importantes
para avaliar se você consegue fazer a
conversão do asto fólico no metilfolato
mutação do
mthfr agora pessoal e os riscos da
deficiência falando da B9 do folato
natural Quais são os problemas de uma
deficiência de vitamina B9 primeiro você
tem que manter os níveis adequados de
folato porque é essencial pra saúde
cardiovascular neurológica imunológica e
para o desenvolvimento fetal saudável
quando uma pessoa tem deficiência de
folato ela pode sofrer danos no DNA e
até mesmo prejudicar o pró processo de
reparo do DNA então isso pode levar a
muitos problemas de saúde inclusive ao
câncer como a vitamina B9 é solúvel em
água ela está presente em vários
alimentos Principalmente nos vegetais de
Folhas Verdes escuras a vitamina B9
também está presente nas vísceras de
animais em leveduras nos peixes nos
abacates Então ela é bem abundante em
vários alimentos agora o que que causa
sua deficiência além das mutações que eu
já mencionei a mutação do
mthfr geralmente a deficiência é causada
por alcoolismo pela falta de gestão de
folato natural na dieta também o
tabagismo também é uma causa de
deficiência de folato durante a gravidez
Você pode ter uma queda nos níveis de
folato porque você precisa de muito mais
nessa fase precisa muito mais dessa
vitamina para a replicação celular e do
DNA relacionado ao bebê que está cresc
dentro de você então paraa mulher
grávida uma deficiência de folato é
especialmente arriscada porque pode
levar defeito do tubo neural do bebê ele
pode nascer como espinha bífida e também
com anencefalia malformações de membros
e até complicações cardíacas então é
fundamental você ter um aporte adequado
de vitamina B9 na gravidez se você está
tomando ácido fólico durante a gravidez
não pare por conta própria continue
tomando mas converse com o seu médico e
veja a possibilidade de trocar caso você
tenha a mutação do mthfr nesse caso pode
ser necessário trocar o ácido fólico
pelo meti folato mas se você não tiver
mutação você pode usar o ácido fálico de
maneira tranquila Mas quais seriam Então
os sintomas que você pode estar com
deficiência de vitamina B9 primeiro
função imune prejudicada ficando doente
de forma frequente Você pode ter baixa
energia fadiga cansaço maior pode
perceber que está com m digestão então
muito inchaço abdominal ou se você tem
algum problema como síndrome do
intestino irritável ou disbiose isso
também pode levar uma deficiência de B9
além dos problemas de desenvolvimento
durante a gravidez Você pode ter quadros
de anemia outros sintomas são aftas na
boca língua sensível inchada Você pode
ter mudança de humor irritabilidade
ansiedade piora do Quad de depressão
pode perceber a sua pele mais pálida um
detalhe muito interessante que pessoas
com cabelos brancos ou grisales
prematuros podem estar com falta de
vitamina B9 bem então Vocês entenderam o
problema do excesso de ácido fólico
sintético e o problema da deficiência da
vitamina B9 natural certo então vamos
entender agora sobre a suplementação a
melhor forma de suplementar a vitamina
B9 é com metilfolato que é a fortiva
natural da B9 em doses
individualizadas ajustadas de acordo com
os exames com sintomas queixas e
anamnese geral é importante avaliar os
exames de sangue especialmente os níveis
de ácido fólico que para uma melhor
otimização devem estar entre 15 e 22 no
exame de sangue Além disso devemos
avaliar as mutações genéticas como as
mutações do mthfr as mais comuns é os
snips c677t e a 298c que eu já expliquei
anteriormente outros exames importantes
são homocisteína hemograma completo
vitamina B12 ácido metilmalônico e Zinco
a dosagem do metilfolato para
suplementação pode variar dependendo da
condição de saúde e de todos os fatores
já mencionados mas geralmente fica entre
400 a 1000 microg por dia grávidas e
pessoas com deficiências mais graves
podem precisar de doses mais altas o que
requer avaliação
individualizada é preferível que o me
folato seja utilizado na forma
sublingual mas também pode ser absorvido
por via oral Mas se você puder usar
sublingual seja em gotas tabletes ou
cápsulas é melhor porque essa forma é
mais diretamente absorvida na corrente
sanguínea através da mucosa sem depender
do trato gest cório isso torna a
suplementação mais eficaz e mais rápida
é importante lembrar também que o
excesso mesmo de metilfolato pode causar
problemas também doses muito altas podem
elevar a perda do aminoácido super
importante a glicina e até interferir na
absorção do zinco portanto tudo isso
precisa ser avaliado de forma meticulosa
por um profissional qualificado comp
os
[Música]
Aé então muito obrigado pela sua atenção
um grande abraço um beijo no seu coração
você é feira